arthur you you've been studying economy
for how long now i mean
you gave your age to everybody how long
would you say you've studied you i would
assume you're reading all the books that
are out there how long have you been
studying economy
oh probably 50 years 50 years five years
so
from your experience what causes
inflation because right now you're
hearing a lot of talks you market crash
was last year hey it's coming it's
coming you're hearing michael bury talk
about the biggest market crashes coming
he came back on twitter and finally said
it again i think last week
but you're hearing more talks right now
about inflation
um what causes inflation and
how bad can things be if hyperinflation
takes place in the states
yeah let me start off about the cause of
inflation i wrote a piece in the wall
street journal
1974 which was the bitter fruits of
devaluation
the u.s dollar had devalued and gone off
gold
and by that we devalued against other
countries currencies i forecast
double digit inflation i was criticized
roundly at the time
and the double-digit inflation did come
because we devalued the currency
versus the numeraire which is gold and
the other countries
we don't have anything like that today
my view is that that model i used back
then no longer is applicable
because we aren't pegged to gold we
aren't pegged to other currencies at all
what you will see of course is if
inflation does hit
it will show up in the u.s dollar which
is not falling
it will show up in the 10-year bond
yield which is not rising
and it will show up in gold prices which
are not rising
so all today i mean patrick very
seriously uh
i don't see any reason why uh
specifically
uh we should expect higher inflation in
the near term
10-year bond yields are not high gold
prices have not risen
and and the dollar has not been
depreciating in the foreign exchanges
dramatically so
i am not currently terribly panicked
about
inflation but if inflation were to come
back
it would have no constraints there's no
reserve requirement constraints
that would hold that inflation back so
my thought right now is i don't see
inflation on the horizon
uh but if it were to come there are no
constraints
operating out there that would stop it i
hope that's okay
uh no no i'm curious you know what i'm
you're the brains here with this this is
your world i want to learn from you i'm
wrong a lot of times
that's totally fine yeah i want to hear
your perspective so if you like this
sort of short clip from an interview i
did click over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye